-Making his TV debut,
performing "Time Today"
and "Hard for the Next,"
from his new album,
"A Gangsta's Pain,"
here's Moneybagg Yo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jimmy Fallon!
The world
been waiting on this one.
Big Speaker, Moneybagg Yo!
-♪ I just looked at my wrist,
I got time today ♪
♪ I'm crossing
the line today ♪
♪ The hate be so real,
the love be fake ♪
♪ Be bumping they guns
and bumping my tape ♪
♪ Don't go against me
then ask for my help ♪
♪ Go get out your feelings
and get it yourself ♪
♪ Might got the same shoes,
but you ain't gon step ♪
♪ ...you just put out
you could've kept, yep ♪
♪ She got a...he gotta share ♪
-♪ Why ♪
-♪ You can't compete
when you can't compare ♪
♪ Got up
and got herself outta there ♪
♪ I see they put me
on memes and things ♪
♪ Don't speak on my life
without knowing the real ♪
♪ Eight figures a year,
what it cost me to live ♪
♪ Don't hold it,
just say what you feel ♪
♪ But watch your mouth
'fore I fly out your... ♪
♪ To a place
that she didn't know exist ♪
♪ Mediterranean water,
my wrist ♪
♪ Keeping 'em pissed,
how I'm talking my... ♪
♪ Six-figure check
for a show, man, I'm lit ♪
♪ Let's celebrate,
now my bag legit ♪
♪ These...with me with
whatever I'm with ♪
♪ Didn't know who did it,
got everybody hit ♪
-♪ Big bag ♪
-♪ I don't like...,
I don't like... ♪
♪ I don't like nobody ♪
-♪ Nobody, nobody ♪
-♪ We can get gangsta,
we can keep it cordial ♪
♪ How you wanna go 'bout it? ♪
-♪ How you wanna do it? ♪
-♪ I don't backtrack, man,
...that ♪
♪ I don't miss nobody ♪
-♪ I don't miss nothin' ♪
-♪ Left it on seen,
I ain't write back ♪
♪ I don't trust nobody ♪
♪ I just looked at my wrist,
I got time today ♪
♪ ...I'm crossing
the line today ♪
♪ ...cry and be lying
to your face ♪
♪ Slicker than us
gotta know how they play ♪
♪ If the money wasn't straight,
she wouldn't be here today ♪
♪ Ain't it man,
sure know what to say ♪
♪ You ain't me,
so it's hard to relate ♪
♪ How much cash I...off
every day ♪
-♪ Big bag ♪
-♪ Don't play with me ♪
♪ Baby, go play with your... ♪
♪ You seen him in person
he...
♪ A huncho it cost you
a Quavo to book me ♪
♪ Surrounded by... ♪
♪ I'm looking like William,
but that ain't my girlfriends ♪
♪ Bruh I'ma spin on your block,
back to back when I finish it ♪
♪ Look like the world end ♪
♪ I ain't ask for it,
they did it to me ♪
♪ ...exposing they hands
for free ♪
♪ Get caught in the middle,
that's bullseye ♪
♪ You got hit,
but we was targeting he ♪
♪ Popping my...with a capital P
♪ SRT, Redeye, red key ♪
♪ Might be ugly,
but my...precious ♪
♪ She ain't even sneeze,
but still I bless her ♪
♪ I don't like...,
I don't like... ♪
♪ I don't like nobody ♪
-♪ Nobody, nobody ♪
-♪ We can get gangsta,
we can keep it cordial ♪
♪ How you wanna go 'bout it? ♪
-♪ How you wanna do it? ♪
-♪ I don't backtrack, man,
...that ♪
♪ I don't miss nobody ♪
-♪ I don't miss nothin' ♪
-♪ Left it on seen,
I ain't write back ♪
♪ I don't trust nobody ♪
♪ I just looked at my wrist,
I got time today ♪
♪ ...I'm crossing
the line today ♪♪
-Yo, Bagg, let's mess
with the ladies right now!
-♪ I just bought a chick
a Patek ♪
♪ I ain't love her,
I just had to show her status ♪
♪ I just bought a...Patek ♪
♪ Bought a...a Patek ♪
♪ I ain't love her,
I just stepped up her status ♪
♪ Got her cooking in the crib
without no panties ♪
♪ I just jumped off the Lear
like a savage ♪
♪ I done turned another one up,
knowing I'm careless ♪
♪ I can't have love
for these...who capping ♪
♪ Saint Laurent, my attire,
made it a habit ♪
♪ I got more than one,
I done made it a habit ♪
♪ And I wanna know if you gonna
be there when I need you, ooh ♪
-♪ You...with a gangsta
this time ♪
♪ Less than fifty in her Birkin,
then she ain't one of mine ♪
♪ Brightness to your glow ♪
♪ They see the difference
in your shine ♪
♪ Co-dependent, long as you
got me, you never in a bind ♪
♪ Go ape...about you primate ♪
♪ A drinker not a smoker ♪
♪ But for me,
you hit that pound cake ♪
♪ They say I started something
when I had gave you the lamb ♪
♪ And other...they can't see ♪
♪ 'Cause everything
ain't for the 'Gram ♪
♪ I put it down ♪
♪ Another...could never
spoiling her too easy ♪
♪ Make it harder
for the next one ♪
♪ I'd rather put her on game
than run it on her ♪
-♪ Run it on her ♪
-♪ If you can put up with me ♪
♪ You a...soldier ♪
-♪ Gangsta ♪
♪ You one out of one ♪
-♪ The one ♪
-♪ It's the Maybach,
drive itself for me ♪
♪ I better not touch the wheel
in this car ♪
-♪ You one out of one ♪
-♪ This the life when you
loving a star ♪
♪ No cap, I'm just ♪
-♪ Making it harder for the
next...to spoil you ♪
♪ Making it harder for the
next...to trust you ♪
next...to love you ♪
♪ Making it harder for the
next...to please you ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]